The first part of security planning is
to start doing inventory of our assets.
What is that we have which is of value?
And something that is of value of
course, has to have some risk to it.
So there has to be a threat.
That is the source of that risk that
is faced by this particular asset.
So the service is the software,
the hardware,
these are the assets that we have.
And we have to concern
ourselves about securing them.
So, when you think about cyber security
and planning for it, of course,
you have to worry about
all these assets,
or the list of what needs to be
secured has to include all these.
When you talk about the software,
so this is sort of the hardware.
When it comes to software, we're running
operating systems on these servers,
or laptops, or mobile devices.
The databases that store large amounts
of data, perhaps, the services that
are talking about the applications
actually we have on the devices.
Again when it comes to software and
services we have to worry about that.
And of course the databases or
the file systems,
they're storing lots of data,
either structured data or in files.
Some of the data is
going to be sensitive.
Some of it could be highly sensitive.
Could be your Lexile property,
you could in employed accords and
things like that, so of course we
have to say where this data resides.
What kind database, which server,
and are we securing the server,
the database, and
the data that's stored in it.
And whenever you talk about assets and
securing them, securing them from whom?
Are we concerned about
external attackers or hackers?
They could be cyber criminals.
They could be motivated for
some other reason.
Activists, for example,
activists perhaps don't like you or
your business or whatever it is.
So is it remote hackers that concern us,
when it comes to securing all these
assets that we are talking about?
Or it's insiders,
it's employees within the organization